Keith enlighten us here on what exactly
is going on when you first heard this
story you thought what oh boy Wow I mean
you know it was crazy because you know
it took me forever to read the article
just because the in the my phone was
like flooded with like Texas calls
everyone you know making comments you
know people within the organization
outside of the organization and you know
you just shocked you're like wow I can't
believe that this is happening and it
just looks bad I mean I know you guys
are going to have a poll question right
but to me this is worse than I mean that
that the type of attention this is
getting is going to be worse than when
they were thinking like when they won
ten games I mean because this is
something that you know if it's right or
wrong I mean if it's true or not it's
something that you know I feel bad for
Bryan Colangelo if it's not true because
it's something that they may have to
make a decision on him because you know
public opinion people tended we always
say you're guilty until proven innocent
but you're often innocent until proven
guilty and it's just a bad look for the
76ers right now I mean I've never
experienced anything like this
like in all my years of covering sports
okay what did you make of his denial
where he said never posted anything
whatsoever on social media he did admit
that he used one of these burner
accounts which I I think I looked at
that as a mistake and even admitting
that you had one it feels like if you
have one then you might have a couple
more there and you had that ones that
were public and now they're private
right after the story came out so what
do you make of what Bryan had to say you
know right now like what he said is what
you expect him to say you know even if
he's innocent or not I mean you know
typically people get lured up
I don't know in instances like this and
they do their extremely vague you know
what I mean so you know if you you
expect them to say that just like you
know an example like Joel embiid he
snapped earlier on Twitter and then I'll
later he came back and tried to you know
be mr. politically correct and I think
what Brian was doing was he was trying
to be politically correct he wasn't
really trying to address the situation
because when I contacted them you know
that's the same response I got it was
like a cut-and-paste job from what he
what he gave the wringer so to me this
was a statement that he had available
that he was going to go with like right
now until you know other evidence could
come out or if he could you know clear
his name whatsoever I think that he's
just you know I'm lack of a better word
lawyered up and he's just trying to make
sure he doesn't say anything wrong there
were two things I looked at the
immediacy of this with Joe Alan bean and
his relationship with Bryan Colangelo
and it sounds like embiid is placated by
what Bryan Colangelo told him personally
that he's not behind this calling him
some names here talking about dancing at
the Meek Mill concert after complaining
about his his knee injury or knee
hurting and then there's the bigger
picture a potential bigger picture and
that is free agents who may want to play
there
I would certainly give pause to that if
I'm one of these big-name guys so you
want to start with embiid or you want to
start with free potential free agency or
on the impact it could have potentially
you know I think let's start with the
the potential free agents you know
you're exactly right I mean if you're
potential free agent and you're looking
at this and I'm just using the word that
you know people people family use the
younger the younger people it's a hot
mess I mean it's one of these things
where you don't want to go to an
organization where you know where a
general manager or president is is
rumored or not rumored or report it to
has burner accounts where he's
criticizing people and and the thing is
you know these are certain things that
you know some of the things that came
out or certain things that you know
reporters knew like for instance embiid
we knew that
you know the sixers warrant you know
happy with the way in bead was doing
things like they weren't happy that he
was at the meek Millz concert dancing
now publicly they wouldn't come out and
say it but you knew it behind closed
doors that they weren't happy so if
you're like a LeBron James or you some
or or a Paul George do you want to come
into a situation like this no I mean you
know think about it right now this is
the time for the draft so the Sixers are
on the west coast right now going
through these agent run workouts when
they're walking in the gym other teams
are like wow look at them they're not
saying hey Bret brown hey Brian
congratulations on winning 52 games and
getting through the playoff they're
saying man where it is the gym has a
burner account no fly above them so this
isn't good and in regards to MB you know
and B is a is a is a huge has a huge
personality you know he's a guy that you
know they say Sam hinkie said trust the
process well people in Philadelphia will
tell you that he is the process and also
being a part of the process and being
for lack of you know just being real
with you he gets it he does a lot of
things that he wants to do I mean you
know think about it he criticized the
team and criticized them for not playing
him like early in the season they wanted
to have a minutes restriction next thing
you know he gets increased minutes right
and then and B the second time when when
they lose Game two to the Miami Heat
he says I'm sick and tired of this and
he wants to play next thing you know
game three and B is playing so MB does
have a lot of power within the
organization and you know so is one of
those things where you know I don't know
if you know it's just it's just hard man
it's hard to say that like you would
think that Bryan Colangelo what it says
some things that can be behind closed
doors like hey I don't like this you
know you know you know a man-to-man
conversation with them but the things
that were said are things that everyone
knew that the Sixers didn't like no but
it was to a point that and beed has so
much power he has so much power that he
basically does what he wants to do one
other thing we're talking to keep
Pompeii the 76ers reporter Ben Simmons
was asked about could he play with
LeBron James I think TMZ approached him
in Los Angeles and he said well only one
way to find out there you know what do
you make of that how strong is that
relationship it's one thing to have
friends it's another thing to want to
play with friends or business
acquaintances that's a funny comment
because that's something that Ben would
say I mean and some people will take it
as a negative but Ben is like the type
of guy like he you have to want he has
to warm up to you it's not you're gonna
have you asked him a question he's going
to give you like a vague answer um I
think that you know they both need the
ball we know that but I think it's to a
point where Ben knows that LeBron has
him in his best interest and if you know
if bran would be there I think LeBron
would demand so much out of him just
like you're a coach and you're coaching
your son you're gonna hold him to a
higher standard than anyone else
so whereas Ben may not have the ball in
all situations like he that he likes but
he knows within two years whenever
LeBron is about to leave that Ben
Simmons is going to be a better player
with that being said I could see that
Ben Simmons welcoming LeBron but let's
just say if it's another ball dominant
player that the 76ers want to being I
don't think Ben Simmons would would
would uh what would would take that and
I also believe that Ben Simmons would
have said to TMC that no I don't think
we can play together I'll let you go
back to work he's you got some stories
to cover here I might be talking to you
tomorrow Keith the way this is playing
out but thanks for joining us yeah but
man this is a really slow day you know
that bad timing award there to the
Sixers Thank You Keith
that's a Keith Pompeii 76ers reporter
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]